comme beaucoup j'ai toujours adoré noël
mais quand on est maman c'est beaucoup
de travail
entre les courses les paquets à faire la
cuisine la décoration tout ça en bois
par an du corps par un parcours et des
images de corps c'est d'ailleurs cet
héritier on n'a souvent pas temps d'en
profiter et il n'ya qu'une seule chose
pour nous qu'est ce qu'il ya ils peuvent
augmenter votre stress ma mère va
débarquer pour nous tout se passera bien
c'est la personne qui la plus critique
de la planète
elle ne changera pas donc ça va pas bien
se passer maman bonjour je viens pour
voir ma fille
un pack noël c'est pas rien j'ai
tellement hâte de passer cinq petites
minutes avec toi ou et on avance et plus
le temps j'étais hyper occupait pas à
faire de la gym europe
j'ai 34 ans et ma mère se croit encore
obligé de me dire que je dois faire ma
mère à moi elle a fait la même couleur
est la même qu'au près moi vous trouvez
ça normal nous n'utilisons jamais le mot
normal tu vas être ma meilleure amie
pour la vie y est je vais organiser une
fête de noces dans ma maison
oui et j'ai invité 184 personnes
combien ça coûte et nous donner un prix
à la machine faudrait juste profiter de
noël cette année plus une mère mère ne
prend pas de plaisir elle donne du
plaisir sur continue comme ça il va
falloir l'affronter physiquement je veux
pas présenter ma mère bien marc schmidt
pour messi sait s'amuser à nolay demande
on va retrouver des primeurs mais tout
est fini les cadeaux parfaits
fini les décos parfaite y en a marre que
la perfection dans festivités de noël
c'est pas obligatoirement premier truc
qu'il a l'esprit mais bon vous avez pigé
[Musique]
ma fille me trouve extrêmement dur avec
elle met lui-même en dribble une fois
elle m'a giflé parce que j'avais porter
des sandales sur un bateau de plaisance
c'était très différent à l'époque
c'était il ya deux mois passés dans son
hall b au delà c'est mon premier rencard
avec le père noël numéro de tulle a
connu comment les bleus s'est révélé
plus tôt
de chanter il y a des yeux tout cette
fois je pense que je suis la 5g de notre
groupe
tu ouvre la bouche elle est brillamment
bal de promo et du coup je me sens
rassuré
[Musique]